Bonjour et bienvenue dans cet épisode un
petit peu spécial...
Pardon.
J'ai jamais fait ce genre d'intro, et je le
referai plus jamais.
-J'y compte bien.
Mais aujourd'hui on va non pas parler d'un
fait historique, ni d'un événement historique,
non non non.
On va parler d'un courant historique.
-Le truc de Volta là?
-Tu sors.
Loin.
-Et lance le générique, au passage!
La microhistoire est un courant historique
apparu dans les années 1970 en Italie.
-Comme toutes les bonnes choses.
-Son nom d'origine est donc microstoria.
Il commence par s'exprimer dans une revue,
Quaderni Storici, et arrive en France dans
les années 1980.
L'idée est simple: se détacher de l'histoire
qui observe des phénomènes de grande ampleur
et se rapprocher de l'individu.
Changer d'échelle, en gros.
Aliénor avec une échelle
Il s'agit donc plutôt d'une histoire sociale,
culturelle, bref, tout ce que j'aime.
Bien sûr son but n'est pas de supplanter
les autres courants historiques, mais de proposer
une alternative, une autre manière de faire
de l'histoire.
A l'époque, le courant historique majeur
est appelé l'histoire quantitative et fait
ce que vous connaissez sûrement le mieux:
extraire des informations de documents, en
tirer des conclusions générales, et les
vérifier sur le long terme.
Dans ce type d'approche, on préfère la régularité
aux accidents: une idée qui se vérifie
largement, comme par exemple le fait que l’Église
avait une grande importance dans la société
médiévale, sera recherchée dans les sources
jusqu'à ce qu'on en trouve suffisamment de
preuves et qu'on puisse en faire un bouquin.
Les exceptions à cette idée sont des exceptions
et donc bah on s'y intéresse pas trop, en
résumé.
Les partisans de la micro-histoire, au contraire,
sont ceux qui appliquent le mieux l'idée
que c'est l'exception qui confirme la règle.
Ils considèrent l'histoire quantitative comme
trop descriptive et n'allant pas assez dans
l'analyse.
Pour Eduardo Gredi, par exemple, une société
se lit davantage grâce à ses marges que
grâce à son centre; Carlo Ginzburg, un
autre historien très connu de ce courant,
explique tout simplement sa réflexion:
« Il faut partir du sable dans l'engrenage.
Si on prend les règles pour point de départ,
on risque de tomber dans l'illusion qu'elles
fonctionnent, et de passer à côté des anomalies.
Mais si on part des anomalies, des dysfonctionnements,
on trouve aussi les règles, parce qu'elles
y sont impliquées ».
-On parle alors d' «exceptionnel normal»:
l'exceptionnel nous permet de mieux comprendre
la norme tout en connaissant ses limites.
Mais dis-moi, la Prof? Comment ça se passe
concrètement? Prendre un air interloqué.
-Eh bien c'est très simple: comme je le
disais, on change d'échelle et on se rapproche
de l'individu.
De préférence, des groupes ou des individus
qui ne sont pas spécialement importants,
qui peuvent être représentatifs de leur
catégorie sociale ou pas.
On essaie de reconstituer leur vécu et surtout
leur univers mental: à partir de là seulement,
on pourra mettre en évidence les structures
invisibles qui les relient à la société,
et donc mieux comprendre le monde dans lequel
ils vivent, leurs relations sociales, etc.
-D'accoooord...
J'ai pas compris.
-L'exemple le plus poussé pour moi est le
livre Le monde retrouvé de Louis-François
Pinagot d'Alain Corbin.
L'historien voulait parler d'un inconnu du
XIXe siècle et reconstituer sa vie et son
univers: pour ça, il va chercher dans les
registres d'Etat-Civil du département de
l'Orne, prend un ouvrage au hasard, une page
au hasard, et pointe son doigt sur un nom
au hasard.
Il tombe sur Louis-François Pinagot, dont
il ne sait alors rien: à partir de là,
il fait son travail d'historien et recherche
dans les archives tout ce qui pourrait lui
permettre de reconstituer son univers: actes
d'état-civil, recensements, listes électorales...
Louis-François Pinagot était jusque là
un anonyme qui n'avait jamais cherché à
laisser la moindre trace de lui: on retrouve
juste une croix sous son nom, écrite sur
un registre électoral à la fin de sa vie.
Il était analphabète et n'a donc jamais
rien écrit d'autre que cette petite croix.
A force de recherches, il peut déjà reconstituer
une partie de sa vie: Louis-François Pinagot
est né en 1798 à Origny le Butin, il était
un pauvre sabotier qui a vécut toute sa vie
en lisière de forêt, son père était voiturier.
Il épouse une fileuse et a huit enfants,
puis meurt à l'âge de 78 ans sans avoir
quitté son village.
Le travail d'Alain Corbin ne s'arrête pas
là: puisque son sujet d'étude a laissé
si peu de traces de lui, l'historien cherche
à reconstituer le «possible» et le
«probable»:
-Louis-François Pinagot fréquentait la taverne
du village.
-Possible.
-Il a vu défiler les régimes politiques,
et les prussiens en 1870
-Probable.
-Il ne connaissait pas l'histoire de la Révolution
Française aussi bien que nous.
-Possible.
-Il gagnait mal sa vie, et sa femme aussi.
-Probable.
-Sa vie et sa mort n'ont absolument pas marqué
la GRANDE Histoire.
-Simple.
Basique.
Alain Corbin cherche donc à aller plus loin,
en cherchant dans les archives du village,
de la région, en se documentant sur le salaire
moyen d'un sabotier de cette région, sur
la forêt près de laquelle il vivait, les
affaires judiciaires de son époque, la diffusion
du droit de vote dans sa commune, le rapport
des contemporains aux changements politiques
fréquents du XIXe siècle...
Bref, à travers l'étude de Louis-François
Pinagot, il brosse un portrait de ce qu'était
la vie dans les campagnes pauvres du XIXe
siècle.
Et ça, c'est de la microhistoire.
-Donc on pourrait faire un livre d'Histoire
sur moi?!
-Et le fait que tu aie voyagé dans le temps
jusqu'au XXIe siècle, c'est de l'exceptionnel
normal?
-Gnggngn.
-Un autre ouvrage très connu et plutôt fondateur
de la microhistoire est celui de Carlo Ginzburg:
Le fromage et les vers, l'univers d'un meunier
du XVIe siècle.
-De plus en plus passionnant.
-Il s'intéresse à la vie de Menocchio, un
meunier du Frioul qui subit une série de
procès.
Cette fois on a donc de nombreuses traces
de son existence et même des écrits de lui,
qui nous livrent ses réflexions sur le monde.
Carlo Ginzburg fait donc son petit travail
d'historien-enquêteur et voilà une reconstitution
de la vie d'un meunier du XVIe siècle qui
cette fois sortait un peu plus de l'ordinaire.
Et enfin, j'en arrive au livre qui m'a donné
envie de faire cet épisode: Le plancher
de Joachim, de Jacques-Olivier Boudon.
Cette fois, le travail de l'historien part
d'un document laissé par son sujet d'étude
et plutôt exceptionnel: Joachim était
menuisier, dans le village des Crottes près
de Gap
-Un beau village de bouseux.
-Et il a tenu une sorte de journal sous le
plancher qu'il posait dans le château de
Picomtal entre 1880 et 1881.
Il s'agit d'un témoignage exceptionnel:
Joachim ne se contente pas d'écrire quelques
notes sans réfléchir, mais il livre ses
pensées en sachant qu'il ne sera pas lu de
son vivant, il sait que le plancher ne sera
pas changé avant plusieurs décennies.
Il a donc une vraie volonté de laisser une
trace de sa vie, de la documenter...
-Et comme il sait que personne de son entourage
ne le lira il se lâche pas mal sur ce qu'il
pense des mœurs de son époque et des habitants
du village.
-Comme il le dit lui-même: «Heureux
mortel.
Quand tu me liras, je ne serai plus». «Mon
histoire est courte et sincère et franche,
car nul que toi ne verra mon écriture.»
-Le plancher n'a été changé qu'en 2000,
par les nouveaux propriétaires du château
qui ont alors découvert ses écrits: 72
planches de textes plus ou moins longs, que
Jacques-Olivier Boudon a retranscrits, croisés
avec toutes les autres archives possibles
pour vérifier les dires de Joachim, et analysées.
Le but, encore une fois: reconstituer la
vie dans un village des Hautes-Alpes de la
fin du XIXe, à partir d'un témoignage très
précieux et intime.
La vie de Joachim est simple mais en cela
tout à fait représentative de son époque:
il est né en 1842 dans le village où il
a vécu.
Son père était menuisier avant lui, sa mère
était protestante.
Une seule de ses sœurs atteint l'âge adulte,
sur les huit enfants qui naissent.
De son côté, il a quatre enfants dont un
seul meurt en bas âge.
-Il sait lire, compter, dessiner, et s'intéresse
à l'Histoire: il parle de quelques événements
historiques dans ses textes, et d'affaires
judiciaires du XIXe siècle.
-Quand il était jeune, il était aussi ménétrier:
il jouait du violon dans les fêtes de village
de la région, ce qui était apparemment un
bon plan pour pécho.
-Il parle beaucoup de son petit village, que
l'historien complète de nombreuses informations,
du château de Picomtal où il travaille et
de la famille qui y vit, de son métier de
menuisier dont il se plaint qu'il rapporte
trop peu.
«5 heures.
Je viens de manger un morceau de cochon qui
vaut 1,10 franc la livre et un verre d'eau
sucrée.
Voilà mon existence, toujours seul au château.
Je m'ennuie.»
«Je siffle et suis gai et pourtant j'ai
fait le plancher sans goutte de vin, réduit
à boire l'eau sucrée et quelque bâton de
chocolat par ma conduite déréglée.
Sois plus sage et tu seras heureux.
Martin.»
Il parle de l'inflation, surtout du prix du
vin qui est multiplié par 10 durant sa vie,
et s'intéresse à la politique du village
mais aussi de la France: la laïcisation
de la République et de l'école, la colonisation...
Il commente aussi pas mal la sexualité au
village, ce qui nous en donne un aperçu au
delà des discours officiels et religieux
de l'époque: il dit être témoin d'un
infanticide, pratique qui n'est pas rare à
cette époque où la contraception est quasi
inexistante.
Tout le monde sait qu'elle existe, sans en
parler, et les procès pour infanticide sont
très rares.
-Il est aussi au courant de quelques adultères
au sein du village et n'hésite pas à les
balancer, sous ses planches.
-Il ne parle pas de sa propre sexualité,
mais semble juste étonné que sa femme était
encore vierge quand ils se sont mariés.
Il balance aussi une affaire de pédophilie,
sur un personnage qui disparaît du village
par la suite et qui n'a jamais été poursuivi.
Après avoir écrit sous ses planches, entre
1880 et 1881, il retrouve l'anonymat à part
dans une lettre qu'il écrit quelques années
plus tard pour pétitionner contre l'abbé
du village.
Le reste de son histoire appartient donc à
l'historien, qui a effectué une démarche
qui aurait sûrement plu à Joachim tant il
semblait attaché à l'idée de documenter
sa vie et le temps qui passait.
Ses enfants quittent le village, pour certains;
l'un part vivre un moment aux États-Unis.
Le dernier reste au village et meurt en 1965.
En bref, la microhistoire est une démarche
historique sérieuse mais aussi un type d'ouvrage
qui rend l'histoire beaucoup plus vivante:
si vous aimez vous plonger dans les mentalités
et dans l'univers de telle ou telle époque,
je trouve que c'est celle qui y parvient le
mieux car elle se rapproche parfois presque
du récit historique, tout en étant très
rigoureuse scientifiquement.
J'espère que cet épisode très historiographique
vous a plu, et peut-être que j'en ferai un
autre un de ces jours sur l'histoire des femmes
cette fois, qui est aussi un courant historique
à part entière.
En attendant vous verrez bientôt débarquer
ici le nouveau Gentes Dames Badass sur Mary
Shelley, après avoir fait celui sur sa mère,
et je vous mettrai en description quelques
ouvrages de microhistoire si vous êtes intéressés
par le genre.
Aurevoir.